did you know
that the fox news christmas tree caught
fire in manhattan it just caught fire
like i don't know i guess someone was
pitching some fire and it caught it
right that's what that was the new york
times headline
fox news christmas tree catches fire in
manhattan
now they've since changed the headline
because it got so much flack
trees don't just catch fire generally
usually someone lights them on fire as
was the case at fox
at fox
someone went up on 6th avenue and let
the tree on fire because they don't like
fox news presumably
just like how suvs don't
don't drive themselves into christmas
parades
they are driven by people
just like guns
don't
just randomly kill people in chicago
we've got a gun problem in chicago we've
got to stop these guns it's not guns
it's criminals those are that's who's
killing people in chicago
it's criminals driving the suv it's
criminals setting the
tree on fire but the libs won't admit
that
the libs are happy to assign blame and
guilt even when it's not real
uh if it fits their narrative like kyle
rittenhouse who shot people in
self-defense who were trying to kill him
they said he's an awful terrible
murderer who needs to be thrown in the
cling forever
but when it comes to
and and that turned out not to be true
and rittenhouse was exonerated but when
it comes to their own guys it's just the
inanimate objects when guests come up to
my door this holiday season this is how
i'm going to greet them i'm going to
greet them holding up these two gigantic
knives to show off the incredible
japanese steel that they are made with
kamikodo makes great japanese steel
kitchen knives using more than 800 years
of traditional techniques from japan
each knife comes in a beautiful wooden
heavy duty box it makes sure that the
knives are stored safely and it makes
kamikodo a great gift each kamikoto
knife goes through a rigorous 19-step
process that takes several years from
start to finish to complete the expert
bladesmiths forge and shape raw steel
into hardy blades polishing and
sharpening them
to an excruciatingly fine edge each
knife is individually inspected kamikoto
is so confident about their knives that
each knife comes with a lifetime
guarantee i really strongly recommend it
kamikoto is currently having a massive
christmas sale and on top of that sale
you can get an additional fifty dollars
off any purchase you make with discount
code knowles canada wles so click the
link below
or go to kamikodo.com
knowles and use promo code knowles
canadawles
to save an extra 50 bucks
today
i am really glad you like that clip i am
i i could not be i could be happier
here's how i could be happier
ring the bell
please i would appreciate it if you ring
the bell you get the notifications you
should also go to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcast you can type in the
michael knowles show subscribe maybe
leave the five star review if you
wouldn't mind
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]